E aí
[Música]
e o mundo inteiro está conectado parece
uma pergunta meio óbvia não é claro que
sim o mundo está conectado temos a
internet é um clique de distância e se
formos um passo além
organizações internacionais que englobam
todos os países e todos indivíduos mas
eu não tô falando essas conexões mais
obras pretendo irmos mais a fundo e
analisarmos o global de perto
e a teoria dos Seis graus de separação
foi criada por Stanley milgram por volta
de 1960 já nessa época ele acreditava
que o mundo estava conectado e Para
comprovar sua teoria o psicólogo
americano fez um experimento onde 300
pacotes fossem enviados de um extremo ao
outro nos Estados Unidos passando por
quantas pessoas fosse necessário no
final do seu experimento sem desse 300
pacotes atingiram o resultado proposto e
para sua surpresa fazendo Coronel mais
do que seis pessoas
então ele descobriu que a fatura estava
correta e ele descobriu o grau de
separação que existia
e agora imagine isso de uma forma um
pouco mais lógica você tem 44 anos e
cada um desses 44 amigos tem 44 amigos
que você não conhece e cada um deles tem
44 amigos que eles não conhecem e assim
por diante numa cadeia de somente seis
Passos você está conectado com 44 a
sexta o que é 7.26 bilhões de pessoas a
primeira coisa que pensamos é nossa como
eu estou perto de pessoas famosas como
em um animal ou Angelina Jolie mas o que
é realmente impressionante é como
estamos perto de pessoas como esquimós
um fazendeiro na Austrália ou até mesmo
um e soldado soviético
muitas teorias muitos estudos foram
feitos a partir disso um dos maiores
deles em 2011 considerando a sociedade
da época Facebook e outras redes Olá
neste foi possível perceber que o grau
de separação cai de seis para quatro e a
tendência é que esse número venha
diminuindo cada vez mais levando a uma
só Conclusão o mundo está assim ao nosso
alcance
agora o que é conexão
seria simplesmente ter acesso wi-fi e ao
computador ou criar laços profundos com
o próximo
ao longo dos meus 3 anos de sala Global
onde pude conversar com pessoas do mundo
inteiro através de uma webcam percebi
que não era nenhuma resposta nem a outra
percebi que conexão é quando a
aproximação entre indivíduos e essa
aproximação traz qualquer tipo de
crescimento pocial é pessoal mas não são
todos que conseguem ver o real valor
dessa e como ela pode transformar o
mundo e somente aqueles que tem olhos
para ver e ouvidos para ouvir vão tirar
o maior proveito disso
e é mas agora essas pessoas cegas e
surdas pela sociedade conseguem começar
a enxergar o mundo de uma forma
diferente como um amigo meu que não
tinha a menor interesse em assuntos como
causas sociais e causas políticas e
achava que como ele não tinha interesse
ele não tinha que tem nada a ver com
aquilo
quando eu falei para ele que eu estava
três passos da Malala um dos maiores
símbolos de causas sociais e políticas
Ele simplesmente não acreditou Então fui
mostrar para ele que o mentor meu tem
uma conexão com um gelzinho que é o pai
da mala então consequentemente estamos
conectadas
eu falei para ele também que eu não vi
aquela conexão como mera obra desiste
não que mesmo alguma de suas causas não
sendo as mesmas que as minhas elas me
impactavam de alguma forma
alguns dias se passaram e ele veio falar
para mim como a nossa conversa tinha
sido transformadora que ele percebeu que
o mundo estava assim Unido e
consequentemente o problema de um também
é problema de todos
agora gostaria de falar um outro caso
que a teoria da Separação se aplicou
para mim eu tenho uma amiga que conheci
através da escola essa minha amiga me
chamou para fazer parte de um trabalho
voluntário e neste ela me apresentou a
uma professora que também era delegada
brasileira da ONU ela me apresentou a
Mateus e vi um representante da Unicef
da Suíça Olimpo de conversar no evento
chamado next Global sementes em
2001/2009 19 o cartão educação inclusiva
educação brasileira e maneiras de
melhorar isso não cenário Global
agora que vocês me conhecem vocês estão
a um passo de distância de todos que eu
conheço
e no final dessa reunião eu só conseguia
pensar em uma única frase eu não consigo
lembrar dos livros que li muito menos
das refeições e come mas mesmo assim
elas me informaram de Ralph Waldo
Emerson eu só conseguia lembrar dessa
frase Pois ela me lembra que todos que
já passaram por mim todas as
experiências que já vivi me tornar uma
pessoa que eu sou hoje e me formar uma
pessoa que eu era aquele dia uma menina
com apenas 16 anos conseguiu realizar um
dos seus maiores sonhos somos um
compilado de tudo e todos que já
cruzaram nosso caminho sejam estranho
que te deu bom dia na rua seja um mentor
que te acompanha por década todos têm um
impacto sobre nós
cada pessoa nova que conhecemos é uma
abertura para o mundo completamente
diferente
e agora qual seria a melhor maneira de
reinicializar depois de ervas para
endêmicas de 30 divisão do que criar
novas conexões
vivemos numa sociedade muito desigual
onde o diferente é visto como algo ruim
ao que deve ser marginalizado ao que não
deve entrar na bolha que criamos mas
devemos parar para perceber que todos
temos algo em comum seja algo simples
como Artes literatura cultura uma coisa
mais profundas como as causas sociais ou
Justiça quando nos colocamos no mundo
descobrimos Vertentes de nós mesmos que
nem imaginamos existir e podemos nos
surpreender positivamente
bom então vamos inicializar vamos nos
conectar Vamos ver até onde a sua voz é
capaz de chegar obrigado a
E aí